or I wasn't gonna do this I even said on
Twitter although you know what not even
gonna do an interstellar spoiler review
I saw a lot of comments on my
interstellar review and a lot of
comments where you just didn't
understand the movie at that point doing
a spoiler review isn't going to get them
to be like oh yeah you're right I was
wrong
you're convinced of something you're
gonna believe it no matter what but I
had a lot of fans like good human beings
like not [ __ ] so we're like I wanted
you to talk about it so for them I do
this spoiler talk of interstellar and as
you consider that a spoiler warning to a
lot of spoilers if you haven't seen
interstellar go see it because like I
said it's a good movie other people miss
that [ __ ] - and be warned that this
video is gonna sound more negative than
I want it to come across as however I
feel like the thing I have to back up in
my initial interstellar review are the
negatives that I found in the movie
generally speaking people don't actually
have to back up their positives people
take their positives for what they are
positive so when a negative and a
Christopher Nolan movie is address
people again they back up and gently
approve it this is me going this is why
I felt there were negatives in a very
positive movie yeah I just got back from
my friend's son's birthday and I was
dressed like this without the suit and I
was like I don't want to dress dad
whatever I'm gonna wear this it's hot as
[ __ ] under these lights but let's do
this let's talk about interstellar
someone interstellar like you knew the
setup was earth is dying crops are dying
and Matthew McConaughey is like the last
person who can go into space and they go
into space and they go through this
wormhole and they find the solar system
with three planets orbiting a black hole
you need to save humanity before we get
there on earth Murph his little daughter
she's like I have a ghost in my room it
keeps knocking down books this was the
first thing to bum me out in the movie
which is simultaneously the last thing
to bum me out in the movie or the last
ish thing to bum me out in the movie
because right when she said that she was
like I have a ghost in my room I was
like yeah that's gonna be Matthew
McConaughey at the end of the movie I
[ __ ] you not asked a few people who had
seen the movie I was like alright was
that obvious to you they're like yeah it
was when foreshadowing is that in your
face for a movie like this you can't
help but feel like good compromises the
experience a bit and people out there
might say for some [ __ ] as weird reason
well you're supposed to know but it's
all about the journey getting there no
you're not supposed to actually know
that I just thought is that really
obvious Christmas gift that gets put
under the tree two weeks before
Christmas like I'm Merry Christmas Timmy
but don't open until Christmas and
that's always a bummer when that happens
that Matthew McConaughey goes they go
through the wormhole they come to the
solar system they like alright we need
to go to these planets right we're gonna
go to that one planet where relativity
is really strong one hour down there
seven years our time
that was really cool I love relativity I
love time that was cool [ __ ] I did feel
like this went down there when I know
big tidal wave we need to go let's go
and they go like I said it was a bit
stop there like a No out and I'm not
gonna lie that way was a bit too huge
for my understanding of water when the
waters three feet deep is not going to
produce a wave that's as big is the
final fantasy 7 Leviathan summon then
they get back to the ship it's like oh
[ __ ] it's been like 20 years and as cool
as that was you can tell that that
pitstop was just created so they can
show relativity because that's an
element of the movie and it's cool stuff
we want to see it and now we see it just
wasn't subtle it wasn't moving into the
movie it was a blatant like alright
relativity is coming cool right well
yeah it was it is heartbreaking when he
catches up on messages from Murphy knows
like oh man she's as old as me now this
sucks ass
I say Murphy not his son because who
gives a [ __ ] about his son it was really
cool seeing Casey Affleck in the movie I
did not think oh you're a good character
and I care about you and that's just
where we're going in this movie I would
have preferred the movie made Matthew
McConaughey a single dad with a daughter
and that was that at least at that point
you don't feel like he's just neglecting
his son right down to the very end of
the movie where love is all quantifiable
and [ __ ] and he sees his daughter not a
son you know it sounds like well thanks
dad that's awesome yeah what what am I
not quantifiable do you not give a [ __ ]
thanks buddy that's rad peace then they
go to the second planet where they meet
Matt Damon doctor man could you make it
any more obvious that this guy
represents man or at least one aspect
and dynamic of mankind the only way that
you can make it so in-your-face obvious
is naming him doctor man oh they did and
I've seen people say ah doesn't make
sense that he just tried to kill them
all and blow up the ship I mean he
probably could have been like yeah I
lied I was lonely that being said can we
just go to the other planet please the
human race is done you can't really
afford to lose one I kind of took it as
he's been alone for a very long time so
he's probably kind of crazy and nothing
he does is going to make sense but it
did make for a really sweet ass scene
where he opened the airlock and thing
blew him out and it's just spinning and
Matthew McConaughey is like we're dead
unless I can dock with it which is what
I need to do so he just spins and
cadance with the thing which is
absolutely completely impossible to do
but he does it because he's McConaughey
he's docks with that thing and I was
like oh man edge of edge of my seat [ __ ]
right there that was that was badass but
again with no one beating his point over
your head in a not-so-subtle kind of way
he's gonna do it again with this concept
that love is the most powerful force in
the universe and it transcends all space
times
logic everything by making Anne Hathaway
go against the character she's been set
up to be for the entire movie this
entire movie and hathaways been the rock
she's been the one who's like no it's
about the mission the mission the
mission everything else is secondary
second third probably for the mission is
what matters so what does she do she's
like I think we should go to that planet
because my boyfriend's there it was just
so against her characters like Nolan
wanted to show we wanted to prove this
point he wanted to prove that with her
but by doing that you ultimately changed
her character to someone she hadn't been
the entire movie to change a character
entirely like that just flips it on his
head it makes me go oh well why did you
do that but at the end of the movie
Matthew McConaughey gets sucked into the
black hole and Hathaway gets blasted to
the planet where her boyfriend is and
McConaughey gets out he's in this
tesseract is this 3d representation of a
fifth dimensional world Matthew
McConaughey is in now and he's like Olli
[ __ ] I was the ghost and I was like holy
[ __ ] I know so he starts doing SOS
signals and messing with the gravity and
he encodes the information they need
from the black hole into the watch and
Murph's like oh that's the missing
equation now we can bend gravity in
space and [ __ ] cool however that leads
to a hundred different question we know
they can dabble in our universe and they
can see in our universe because they
created the wormhole that took us to
these other planets that we needed to go
to and they knew we needed to go to
those planets so they can see end up
could they have been a little nicer
about it though couldn't they make the
wormhole a little closer to earth rather
than Saturn and the other side of the
wormhole to the planet that we actually
need to go to rather than have us play
the guessing game as the little which
planet do we actually go to they used to
be like here here's the correct answer
you're welcome can they actually weave
in and out of time could they've taken
Matthew McConaughey and just kind of
plopped him on earth right after he left
and like all right here Murphy now you
have your life back and [ __ ] did Matthew
McConaughey need to be going towards the
black hole in order for the fifth
dimensional beings to snatch him up
could they just taken someone from Earth
at any time I've been like it showed him
going through the wormhole in which guys
did he get to the wormhole to the fifth
dimensional beings take him there so
they don't actually operate within the
black hole they can really go anywhere
when you have fifth dimensional beings
and you don't do a good job at
illustrating what they can and cannot do
obviously they can do a lot it leaves
some questioning where you're like wait
a minute they could have done that
better I take the fact that the fifth
dimensional beings couldn't directly
communicate with us because the same way
that we can't communicate with the 2d
world how would a three dimensional
being communicate with a 2d world they
wouldn't be able to see us because
they're like right
in front of each other and were it
doesn't work so how much harder is it
for them to communicate with us best
thing you can do is take one of us and
have us communicate with us I get why it
had to be Matthew McConaughey none of
the other astronauts hadn't you loved
ones at home so they didn't have that
quantifiable love with them it's a thing
in the movie I'll explain later
imagine McConaughey was the only one the
first one in history who actually had
the data to complete the formula and had
that quantifiable love tied to earth
which was Murphy so they snatched him up
put him in the thing so we can get code
the message to Murph and all's right
with the world
and then it's like love is quantifiable
at that point I was like the movies no
delved into magic it's kind of laughable
I was I just couldn't see that [ __ ]
movie so ground into science now love is
quantifiable I just feel like at this
point any cheesy romantic comedy you've
ever seen a romance in general that puts
love on this pedestals like oh but we're
meant to be together he's kind of got to
give it one more star because it's like
well apparently it's quantifiable now
it's science just maybe go just Nolan
turning into a sappy guy the thing that
bothered me about the movie is the
resolution itself between him and Murph
the entire movie is based on the fact
that he wants to get back to his
daughter and his daughter hates him for
a lot of the movie and then it's like Oh
Lea [ __ ] my dad was right I really want
to be with him also and now he gets back
and he has about 30 seconds with a
nine-year-old version of her before
she's like oh I'm dying and I want to
die with my own family now so you should
go really with that that's kind of
suffer like see it through his eyes see
what you're doing to him his love for
you was so big it was quantifiable it
saved the human race literally basically
that's what happened I'm just gonna tell
him to go piss off and go away so as he
mopes and then goes away he goes to Anne
Hathaway's planet whose boyfriend his
dad did he go there knowing that as far
as he knew her boyfriend was alive is he
going there to be like hey I'm a home
wrecker or is he going there planning on
being the third wheel like the friend
like alright you guys just have your
relationship I'll be you know hanging
out skipping rocks on that pond some of
this science things that were
questionable in this movie is all right
they don't orbit a Sun so where are they
getting their heat and light from yes I
know black holes have the ring around
them and that's energy and that's heat
it's eventually really really hot but is
it hot enough to heat three different
planets at three different distances
unless they're all in the same orbital
path in which case they're probably
going to collide with each other
obviously not because one of them is
really freezing another one has
water another one looks like earth but
there are at different temperatures I'm
just saying are they all in the safe
zone or could you clearly look at one of
your like that's going to be too cold
let's go there by Matt Damon he's
pinging on that planet he says it's good
I don't care it's obviously better than
that so the question is could the ring
around the black hole heat all three
planets and he told them to a safe
temperature to sustain human life and if
they couldn't couldn't you just
eliminate them just as options be like
alright it's not heating that one enough
we know that so why if you're like from
orbit of a planet you can kind of gauge
whether or not it's 100% water if we're
like mmm going away but just bring up a
really interesting financial question
about the movie NASA was disbanded it
lost its funding years prior however
they had enough funding to send goes at
12 to 15 people out there to these
planets how did you get the money for
that
holy [ __ ] how much it cost to send
something into space like that a space
exploration mission like this cost a lot
of money how do they get that with no
funding also why send astronauts each
ship has that robot that's innocent why
not just send the robots and I know the
movie explains you can't just send the
robots because they don't have that
survival instinct that human beings have
whatever the [ __ ] that means I don't see
it that way in a movie in a world where
love is quantifiable and very sure you
can measure the conditions of the planet
and it is whether or not human beings
could live there all you have to do is
be like hey robot here's what human
beings need to survive here are the
living conditions find the planet if it
has it ping us back if it doesn't don't
ping us feel like Matt Damon should have
been like you know why they can't send
robots as mr. Nolan says if we sent
robots you couldn't have a movie and
that would be true that's pretty much
why instead of that explanation couldn't
you just make a movie with no robot in
it and that would eliminate the
possibility of sending robots there no
robots you can't have the option to send
robots you don't have to write up a
[ __ ] explanation as to why you
couldn't send robots granted I liked the
robot I thought he was a cool character
but he just poses a problem for the plot
when the enterprise runs up against the
situation who are they sending first
Lieutenant Commander data that's who's
going in the end I'm going to reiterate
interstellar was a fun movie it was a
good movie you should see the movie the
movie just had problems that I've
already explained so I don't need to go
over him again I'm an astronomy fanatic
and a movie fanatic this should have
been my jam so yeah an answer your
question I got the movie I just didn't
feel the movie was executed as well as
it could have been executed and at that
point it's still a movie it's not church
it's not gospel it's not a science
textbook it's a movie and as a movie
yeah movie is good
see it's just not the greatest movie
made in the past 30 years is all if you
disagree with me on my consensus of
interstellar that is fine if you think
I'm a piece of [ __ ] because I feel the
movie is good and not mine bellowing Lee
[ __ ] gray spoiler alert I can think
of 10 movies right now that I like
better than interstellar this year
interstellar is not going to be in my
top 10 favorite movies of the year of
2014 so if that bothers you so much if
you hate that so much there you go if
you can handle it awesome eh see you
next time so that's my consensus of
interstellar do you agree all that good
[ __ ] comment below let me know and as
always if you like we've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more